yes
i'm surprised
i need to connect
yes
hello
okay
awesome
thank you
either way
you're good
hello
so
um
is
is
this is
okay
oh
hmm
thank you
oh
foreign
so
thank you
mm-hmm
uh
yes
so
good afternoon and thank you secretary
azar for joining us today at cdc
headquarters
it's a privilege to have you with us and
we appreciate your leadership
throughout this unprecedented response
19 is the most significant public health
challenge our country's faced
in more than a century
and the pandemic is not over earlier
this week covenvirus cases reached
over 40 million globally here in the
united states we're approaching
a critical phase in a few moments
dr jay butler cdc's deputy director for
infectious disease
and the former incident manager of the
cdc's
covet 19 response will provide you a
brief update on
our current domestic situation
i know it's been a difficult year for
americans
but we are going to come through this on
the other side
i'm also optimistic that we'll have a
limited supply
of one or more coveted vaccines
available for distribution before the
end of this year
but we're not quite there yet that is
why it's so important that all of us
remain
diligent in our efforts to defeat this
virus
and to protect ourselves our families
and our communities
at cdc science data
and service have driven our
unprecedented
response to the coven 19 pandemic
and our mission is to protect the health
of
every american and save lives
personally i'm incredibly proud of the
men and women of cdc
and it's truly been an honor for me to
lead them
during these extraordinary times and to
lead these extraordinary people
i would like now to introduce dr jay
butler who will
make remarks and then followed by
secretary of
health and human services alex cesar and
then we'll be happy to take your
questions
jay
good afternoon everybody thank you for
being here it's fabulous to be able to
speak to you today
and thank you for that introduction dr
redfield
we're here to give you the latest on
what's going on with dakota 19 pandemic
unfortunately we're seeing a distressing
trend here in the united states with
coca-19 cases
increasing in nearly 75 percent of the
country
today we've confirmed over 8.1 million
cases and sadly over 220
000 deaths since january i know these
are numbers
but these are also people and we mourn
these losses
the past week we've seen nearly 60 000
cases a day
on average as well as 700 deaths
here in georgia we've also seen an
increase in the number of cases despite
the decline
that we had experienced beginning in
august
and we're also seeing cases increase in
really all parts of the country
uh in the midwest particularly likely in
part because
people are moving indoors with the
arrival of cooler temperatures
another factor is that smaller more
intimate gatherings of family friends
and neighbors
may be driving an infection as well
especially as these gatherings move
indoors and adherence to face coverings
and social distancing
may not be optimal i recognize that we
are all getting tired of the impact that
coca-19 has had on our
lives we get tired of wearing masks but
it continues to be
as important as it's ever been and i
would say
it's more important than ever as we
moved into
the fall season it's incredibly
important to continue these steps also
as we look towards the upcoming holidays
we know that every activity that
involves interacting with others
has some degree of risk right now
there are four general rules of thumb
for assessing
risk and deciding how to best protect
yourself
and those you love first the more
closely you interact with
others second the longer the interaction
asks
third if the interaction is indoors
rather than outdoors
and fourth interactions with the
greatest number of
people translate into the higher risks
of coded 19 spread understanding these
risks
and how to adapt different prevention
measures can help you protect yourselves
and your families and your communities
we all want to live as safely as we can
and minimize the risk of coping 19
while it is circulating secretary hasar
will highlight what people can
do to protect themselves but i want to
spend a few minutes talking about an
additional tool
we'll likely have very soon decoded 19
vaccines
as dr redfield mentioned we're
cautiously optimistic
that vaccine will be available although
likely in limited quantities before the
end of 2020. preparing for
implementing a successful coca-19
vaccine program
is a crucial next step as part of our
overall effort
to protect americans reduce the impact
of the kova 19 pandemic
and continue to restore more normalcy to
our lives
and our country cdc is a proud part of
operation workspeed
the partnership between parts of hhs and
the department of defense
to develop make and distribute millions
of coded 19 vaccine doses as quickly as
possible
while ensuring that they are safe and
effective
in other words we want to make sure they
work
i'm pleased to announce that all
jurisdictions including georgia
have submitted their initial vaccine
program plans
these plans are an important milestone
in our efforts to ensure
successful delivery and administration
of safe and effective coded 19 vaccines
to the ultimate goal that everyone who
wants to be immune
can be over the past month
cdc has provided technical assistance to
each jurisdiction
including nearly daily check-ins with
jurisdictional staff
weekly conference calls with
immunization and preparedness
managers and in some cases on-site
assistance
my colleagues are currently conducting a
thorough review of the draft plans we'll
be providing feedback to the
jurisdiction
during the next two weeks it's important
to recognize that these
plans are flexible because things may
change as we learn more about which
vaccines
become available and what amounts and
when
additionally each plan will include an
executive summary that we plan to post
online later this month
allowing for maximal transparency and a
general
understanding of each jurisdiction's
approach
i want to highlight also the pharmacy
partnership we announced last week with
cvs and walgreens
again we anticipate that initially the
vaccine will be available
in a limited supply and when the limited
when the supply vaccine is limited our
efforts to vaccinate
may need to focus on those who are at
highest risk of severe disease
as well as those critical to the
response including those who provide
care to people in the health care system
people at risk include those in
long-term care facilities like nursing
homes and assisting living facilities as
well as independent living facilities
the pharmacy partnership for long-term
care program provides end-to-end
management of the coca-19 vaccination
process
including getting vaccines to facilities
it provides for on-site vaccinations
and fulfillment of all reporting
requirements
long-term care facilities will have the
option of partnering with cvs and
walgreens
whose combined national footprint will
allow most facilities nationwide
to opt into this program before i close
i want to remind you that tomorrow the
vaccine and related biological products
advisory committee is meeting to discuss
the latest
latest program 19 vaccine development
and next week the advisory committee on
immunization practices will be meeting
both of these meetings independent
committees will be broadcast live for
the public to see the data
that is being discussed as well as the
process that's being used to ensure
that americans have a safe and effective
variety of coded 19 vaccines
we know that stopping this pandemic is
going to take all of our tools
hand washing masks social distancing
and hopefully quite soon vaccines
taken together these tools are our best
chance of getting our communities
schools
and health systems back into normal
operations
i'd like to turn the podium over at this
point to
alex says our secretary hasar thank you
for being here
well thank you so much dr butler and dr
redfield and thanks to everybody at cdc
for hosting us here today
it's an honor to be here to express
my gratitude to the incredibly
hard-working
team here at cdc for their efforts
throughout this pandemic
while atlanta i've also had the chance
to learn about the heroic efforts of the
healthcare providers the janitorial
staff everybody
at grady memorial hospital as well as
emory university's
hospital's work on clinical trials for
regeneron's antibody cocktail
and modernist candidate vaccine
thanks to how we designed operation warp
speed
if and when the fda gives the go-ahead
for these therapeutic and vaccine
products
we will have supplies already
manufactured and ready for distribution
in conjunction with operation workspeed
the cdc as dr butler mentioned is
leading the effort to coordinate vaccine
distribution
and administration working with the 64
public health jurisdictions they partner
with on vaccines each year
i want to offer a special thank you to
every american who has volunteered for
covet 19 clinical trials
or helped raise awareness especially
among diverse communities where we need
representation in our clinical trials
anyone interested in signing up for a
vaccine trial
can visit coronavirus.gov
and for therapeutic trials go to
riseabid
while we make this exciting progress on
vaccines and therapeutics
we see concerning trends in many parts
of the country as dr butler explained
i'm briefed with the latest data from
across the country by cdc's career
experts each
and every morning there is hope on the
way
in the form of safe and effective
vaccines in a matter of weeks
or months but in the meantime
to bridge to that next phase we have to
take steps that can keep ourselves our
families and our communities safe
those are the three w's wash your hands
watch your distance wear your face
covering when you can't watch your
distance
and avoid settings where you can't do
those things
thank you all for joining us here today
thank you to the american people
for the incredible sacrifices that you
have made throughout this pandemic
and thank you to again to the dedicated
team here at cdc
for their incredibly hard work we're not
happy to take some questions
thank you mr secretary last week emory
university's dean of public health
called your agency's underwriting of the
cdc
under president trump unforgivable
and called the president's leadership
anti-science
dr butler i believe was quoted in
propublica as saying he's deeply
concerned
that actually the agency was forced to
take with us
lives have you discussed any of that
in your conversations today since all
this was last week
and do you have any concerns about the
allegations
well i'm not going to talk about my
discussions internal here within cdc
what did i come down here to do i came
down here to thank the incredible people
of the cdc
for their work we talked about the
most recent data around the
efficacy and importance of wearing face
coverings we talked about the vaccine
planning work around distribution of
vaccines
and i got an update about the incredible
progress cdc is making on increasing the
data submissions from nursing homes into
the national health safety network
in terms of the question that you asked
let me be really clear
the cdc is the premier epidemiological
organization on the face of the planet
when we go to other countries as i often
did before the cope at pandemic
they literally are named the blank
centers for disease control and
prevention named after this very
institution
so this is a crown jewel of american and
global public health
we revere but cdc plays a role
in what is a very unique unprecedented
pandemic it has been 100 years as dr
redfield noted since we have had
a public health crisis of this type this
is bigger than h1n1 this is not stars
this is not mers
this is something that impacts the
entire government and the entire economy
cdc plays a very important role in that
but it plays a role of public health and
epidemiology
there are other key players even within
my department substance abuse mental
health services agency with important
equities around mental health
opioid abuse during the pandemic
nih and fda around research and
countermeasures
the veterans department around care for
our veterans the defense department
around force protection
transportation dhs around transportation
issues international congress the state
department international relations
spread of disease globally so cdc plays
a very important vital role
but in a pandemic of this scope size and
magnitude it plays a role not just
the role and i think some of the people
who comment
are not having actually lived in or led
in this organization during this type of
a crisis
failing to appreciate that but make no
mistake the cds science and evidence-led
organization
we respect cdc's science and evidence
conclusions
what comes out of the cdc at the end of
the day
is dr redfield's conclusions around
science and evidence
the support of this team and that's how
we operate that's how we're going to
keep operating
yes
is
sure thank you very much for the
question
i think just to take the
big picture as we said before c cdc is
science-based and data-driven
and as a consequence as we get more data
and understand the science of covet
we're going to continue to incorporate
that in our recommendations
originally contact as you know that was
considered to be high risk
for potential exposure to covet with
someone
within six feet that was
for more than 15 minutes there is some
recent data
that has been determined
that individual who had a series of
shorter
contacts but over time
added up to more than 15 minutes
became infected and clarifying that new
science
that new data into
our contact recommendation is what
you're alluding to again it's based on
data
that one didn't have four months ago
but it is data now that we have based on
uh situations reported the second part
of your question
um could you say it again for a second i
think
for the effort in quarantine so again as
you know the data that we have right now
uh that's in play is that
individuals who have had a high-risk
exposure
have a period of time after that when
they actually become detectable for
virus
originally the average was a little more
than five days and then
then new data showed it was a little
more than seven days
when you looked at the data collectively
if you did the cutoff
at 14 days you actually identified
almost everyone that was positive
if you tried to shorten it to 10 days we
found that we missed around
maybe 12 percent of people and so
therefore we stayed at the
14 days now all of those decisions were
made without testing
so now there's a series of studies
gathering data
that are trying to determine can you use
testing
during the quarantine to determine if
you could
shorten the quarantine from 14 days
to 10 days or seven days so again
it's data driven it's under evaluation
obviously we don't want to have people
be quarantined for you know 14 days
unnecessarily
so we are working hard to see if there's
data
now that we have testing that may allow
us to be more confident that if we do
testing at day 5 or day 7
that we can use that information then
more effectively understands
that we could shorten the quarantine
period so it's not a policy
it's basically a matter it's an area of
research where we're gathering that data
yeah if again try to say this
many times i get the opportunity science
is a
science-based data-driven service
organization cdc is
we're not an opinion organization so if
we get data
that supports the change in our
recommendations then those
recommendations will be changed
in previous years i think we're up
nearly
hundred thousand deaths and i wouldn't
see that two out of every three deaths
is totally did you just talk about that
true
so the concept of excess deaths is one
that may sound a little cold but
basically life is a sexually transmitted
condition which is 100
fatal so we know that all of us are
going to die eventually
there is a expected periodicity
to that there is the average life
expectancy
we know that at any time there's a
certain amount of
seasonal variation also and this is
uh something that we've looked at for
years in terms of the number of excess
dust that are caused during the
influenza season
using that same type of methodology to
look at what's happened during the
time of the coping pandemic is how we're
able to come up with
the fact that we know more people have
died this year we know that some people
are going to die
no matter what but comparing the total
number
to that expected number leads to a
difference
that ultimately leads to the 300 000
excess
deaths that you've just just mentioned
about two-thirds of those we can link
directly
to code in 19. um
what about the other third that's a you
know an important question to address as
well
some of those may be unrelated
perhaps because of uh limitations on
access to medical care some of them also
may be unrecognized impacts of
probit 19. so when we look at factors
like cardiovascular death that aren't
directly linked to cobit 19
there's not a really great explanation
for why we would see that increasing
cardiovascular death
and we know that it's possible that kova
19 could be playing a role
in those deaths as well overall i think
it emphasizes the importance of the
prevention measures that
we've been talking about
you said that um a vaccine
could be available for distribution
towards the end of the year and i'm
sorry
um does that mean how widely
and um how long do you think it could be
before a mass speed
is available for widespread distribution
to anyone who needs it
that
these are the questions that we are
asking every day as we move forward with
vaccine planning because as you're aware
there's a number of different products
that are currently in clinical trial
there's a process to make sure that
those vaccines are safe
and effective that we have to go through
as well
and a number of the clinical trials are
ongoing and still
in a fairly early phase so i wish we had
a crystal ball so we could look at it i
wish i could say everything is going to
go
100 according to plan but
we also know that we have to be ready
for if it doesn't i think
looking at the current trends
in the studies and the production of
vaccines
it's reasonable to expect that we will
have
at least one possibly two products
available before the
end of the calendar year the next
question is okay
that's when again no guarantees how much
and that's that's also part of the
iterative process as we
continue to learn what production
capacity will be
going forward one of the uh beauties of
operation work speed
is we're not waiting until we have all
the studies completed and the reviews
done before we start
the production process it may be that we
find for instance that a vaccine is not
effective
and that's a vaccine that ultimately is
not going to be administered to
americans
and and if i could just in terms of your
question around the timelines on
on quantities so as dr butler mentioned
we've got the pfizer and laderman
vaccines which are
very close to if not fully enrolled in
their clinical trials
when we get data out of those we'll
really be dependent on events in the
trial
that's outside of anyone's control we
are as dr butler mentioned
concurrently manufacturing commercial
scale production of all six of the
vaccines that we have investments or
contracts with including of course
pfizer and moderna
and we expect that we would have by the
end of this year
enough vaccine to be that is fda
authorized to be able to vaccinate all
of our vulnerable into the most
vulnerable individuals
then by the end of january we expect we
have enough to vaccinate
all seniors as well as our healthcare
workers and first responders
and by the end of march to early april
enough vaccine for all americans who
would want to take a vaccine
like we've got we have an overflow room
because of uh abiding by cdc's
restrictions on number of people in the
room
could i ask do we have anyone on the
phone a question from the phone that
has been asked
we'll turn over to the phone now if
somebody has a question
do we have bloomberg on the phone please
go ahead
um hi uh this is almost for
um we were told by uh
uh operation works today that alpha
seneca and johnson and special trials
are soon this week
uh you broke up a great deal there i'll
try to i believe your question was
regarding the status of the astrazeneca
vaccine clinical trials so
um as of now within the united states uh
unless something has changed in the time
since i've been standing here the uh the
astronomical trial remains on clinical
trial hold here in the united states
because of
uh the review by the fda and the company
uh as to a possible serious adverse
event and
what we do is the company as well as the
fda
examined the data to determine when
there's a serious event
is there a connection to the vaccine do
we believe that's a valid connection
a causative connection um and if so
should the trial be restarted and
continued or are there
other precautions that one should take
for instance modifying informed consent
forms
uh anything about the protocol that's
part of that so the fda has been working
to gather
data and information from astrazeneca
to make to assist in that evaluation and
as far as i know that process is
continuing as we speak that'll be a
determination made by
made by the fda one more okay
yep can we see if the on the phone
who do we have on the phone have fox on
the phone
secretary azar thank you for taking our
questions today
uh the president of the united states
has held numerous rallies around the
country
many in the hottest of no social
hospitals
and little mass wearing the president
also says we are rounding the corner
and simple english are already rounding
the corner
and are these rallies a good idea the
second part of my question sir is the
president
has also been critical of dr fauci
lately what impact do you believe this
will have if your department tries to
distribute
and convince americans to take a vaccine
that many surveys are now showing some
americans
are skeptical about or concerned about
taking
so in terms of in terms of your first
question uh listen our guidance is the
same regardless of setting
wash your hands watch your distance wear
your face carving when you can't watch
your distance and avoid settings where
you can't do this thanks for anybody
reconnected to school reconnected to
work going back to worship
or reconnecting to healthcare or
engaging in
the political and civic life of our
country our advice remains the same
which is wash your hands watch your
distance wear face coverings when you
can't watch your distance and avoid
settings where you don't where you
aren't going to be able to
do those things that that advice is the
same regardless of any type of gathering
uh with regard to your second question
the uh the president is assembled and
has direct access
to many different advisors including the
the people on this stage as well as
others i try to make sure
from the beginning of this of this
outbreak
that the president is getting the best
medical scientific advice from a diverse
range
of the top doctors uh within this
department
uh and the president hears divergent
viewpoints the president's made clear
that he has great respect for dr fauci
and has a close relationship with dr
fauci he said that in follow-up from
those other comments
uh that should have no impact on the
vaccine work that we do
the vaccine work that we're doing the
american people should feel very
reassured
by the process that is established here
there are five independent checks around
vaccine regulation first
a vaccine clinical trial has
pre-specified ending points they're
statistical
and actually these drug companies have
been transparent for the first time in
history
laying out exactly what those
statistical endpoints are
there was a totally independent data and
saw safety monitoring
that will look at the data as it comes
in determine if those endpoints have
been met
if and only if those endpoints are met
that data gets revealed to the company
and the fda
then the company will have its own
second independent process will have to
meet their ethical standards for
submission of an application for rather
an emergency use authorization or a
biologic license
third we'll come to the fda where the
fda will evaluate that vaccine according
to
two sets of guidances put out it's
general vaccine guidance
for covin and its second eua
guidance for what it would require and
expect in terms of approval
then you've got the fourth chapter which
is as dr butler mentioned
the advisory committee at the fda an
external advisory committee that will be
webcast
a public external advisory process will
advise the fda
and then fifth the decision about
whether to approve or authorize a
vaccine at fda will be made by fda's
career scientists
so that's five independent checks that
combined with how this is working so far
look at
look at the fact that we have three
clinical trials that have been put on
hold
because of any type of safety concern
the system's working
this is being played by the book so one
antibody trial has been put on hold two
vaccine trials put on hold
to ensure that fda and we are putting
patient safety at the center
following all regulatory ethical
standards
for development of both therapeutics and
vaccines
all of those elements of process should
reassure the american people
that when a vaccine or therapeutic comes
out with the authorization or approval
of fda
it represents fda's career scientists
best judgment that meets their
scientific evidence legal and regulatory
standards
so thank you all very much for coming
today dr redfield and i've got to get to
the airport
but we really appreciate you being here
today and dr butler very much appreciate
that
as i said dr butler is the senior career
official at cdc leading the corona virus
effort
and we're very grateful to him for his
leadership uh and
i'd like to as we move into the future i
want to make sure
as you have had access we're going to
make sure that there are continued
interactions and opportunities
uh for for you all to be continuing to
engage cdc as well as our career leaders
here thank you very much
so